okay so here's the skeletal line keep
your grip with my arm this is a skeletal
alignment keep going to keep your Navy
guitar so I keep myself over it you see
how I'm doing that and then I can go
down that's a skeleton so keep lifting
keep lifting Tokyo is me leveraging off
of my same projection engine so I am
holding the stability by leveraging off
so when I want to drop my hand I
leverage you off of that same center so
a little alignment okay so skeletal
alignment you see and yes you can chuck
a mask on that okay
whole queue itself internal leverage and
internal leverage okay so you can do the
opposite of skeletal alignment lift it
up lift it up right so same thing you
see go ahead lift it up lift it up you
see Oh same thing see how I'm doing
do you understand what I'm doing though
okay so skeletal alignment it works
because it's mass and matter right but
it's not cookie okay so when you're
doing your coal you're not yet here you
brought the hand
Center and then you move the skeletal on
the forward cute okay so get on level
I'm here and it's it's in here it's not
in here
cher like that okay and then I move the
whole thing and I'm gonna get some cross
viable torque going for conditioning but
it's all here okay so your drill in the
next drill won't here hold it
come on flicks off the center and drop
the center okay let's go
so when I when I do my savuti right I'm
kicking up with that tissue organization
up close the sort oh that's my first
pulsing of it all up come the source
then when it comes down oh I have
another own selection up at the same
tissue organization okay so it's the
same organization that we have in a
projection so boom boom same thing same
flex even when I haven't run into it
when he runs into it reflection no
matter how small you get it
okay so I'm now using that fleshing on
against my own levers okay to give me
more leverage so I don't want you to
think I don't want you to think it's
muscle that's what I was trying to show
here right let's let if I try to use my
my shoulder I can't do it okay but I can
flex off of off of my my center-right
flexing off of it you think so when you
come here you have to watch look I'm
trying to get a mechanical advantage
over him do you understand it's kind of
like here you're trying to get a
mechanical advantage and here you're
trying to get a mechanical advantage so
don't all I'm doing is this okay
you can regrip if he wants well these
other so if you want seek and regrip you
can fix your posture okay it's in here
it's in here and then I just and then I
can just lock it if I what I'm asking
you guys to do is not much just prolong
the flexion right and then you're just
lowering it you can so go ahead and read
it up so you get a good grip do you
understand online have to be at such a
disadvantage I want I want better
weights on the on the bench okay so you
can't pulse it but we're gonna hold it
so he's there right and I just keep that
in here flexing off here and then doing
my take again try it again
okay so you're gonna try that one saying
see my arm is behind me right you see
that my arms not out to the side and he
is he's gonna lift it up lift it up
okay you see all right so I'm gonna
leave it right it is my arm my arm comes
down to leverage it's gonna come to your
side but I'm not pulling it do you
understand maybe here here's me pulling
it BC that's means pulling it I'm going
here okay no I leverage it off off of
that just work it off to the side give
yourself a very much of very much of a
mechanical disadvantage but for this
okay so on here here it really your a
range of exercise is about to here okay
then it then he is just walking into it
you understand
so depend of stop when you get there but
you're here right
I want you to back the divorced side
it's not that that's easy but it's
easier okay so I have them in the back
and then like my to cook you
developments go ahead give me something
to work with
okay so I am trying to take momentum
it's working on my other thing do I take
all the momentum out of out of the
technique right and just keep working
this leverage
time to take a little mention I know I'm
not doing that right now I do the other
ones need more room and my body good
body
I know it's not that strong but I'm
gonna take it out try your work
[Music]